oh look who it is bobo oh
listen i have some breaking news if
everybody wants to tune in to news 13
i'll be on every hour on the hour 5 6 7
all the way up i did another for the
third time they called me back on safety
about being a good samaritan and what to
do what not to do if someone has a flat
tire one on the hour
yeah just looking at the video you know
bobo does a weird thing
he wears a police hat and it kind of
like i think he kind of tries to
insinuate that he has some authority
like it makes him look like he's a
policeman what do you mean
kangaroo
yeah like captain kangaroo was only
captain of kangaroos if you had the
sound off and you were just walking by
the tv you'd be like oh there's a person
in authority maybe a police officer want
to hear bulba discussing the dangers of
bike riding in florida on channel 13
sure i mean just to hear what do you
hear what officer bobo
from as many years as a driving
instructor in new york and now florida
steve bowie is alarmed by the way cars
and bikes interact with each other when
sharing the road as you know cars and
trucks don't mix
and cars and bicyclists certainly don't
mix on our roads he says the main issues
have to do with distracted drivers and
bike lanes sometimes the bike lanes
would just abruptly end
no warning nothing there would be no
bike lane no shoulder in the road for
the bicyclist that puts him in grave
danger what's a bicyclist to do well
according to steve he thinks you should
avoid the road in its entirety beautiful
trails that go for miles right down here
on 434 you you can ride to your heart's
content you don't have to deal with
vehicles steve bowie knows that for now
bicyclists will continue to use busy
roads so at the very least he advises
bikers to wear brightly colored helmets
and shirts the more visibility you have
the more you can be seen by other
drivers on the road
police hat and a cape the more
visibility you have the more you will be
seen well a hat with a power bobo yes
we're looking at you on tv
what's with the police
what's with the police hat that you wear
oh i got i got that a while back from
there that's my friend uh my friend john
yeah you never mind your friend john
your friend john's probably a policeman
he is yeah but you're not i know but he
says here take this i want you to have
it i thought one for 12 years he was
part of my team my safety team
so you know
but don't you think it's misleading to
be wearing a police hat when you're
being interviewed about something no
because i don't have a badge i'm not
having a badge but why don't you dress
up like an astronaut like a full like
you're landing on the moon for your next
thing you know what it is it's part of
the safety gig because i taught with
safety for years and it's and this is
the same thing i'm doing today down here
in florida but you're not a police
officer let me ask you something because
i wear john cena hat does that implied
that i'm a wrestler now oh come on you
know the difference you put on the
policeman's hat so people will think
you're a cop
no no i have
in florida impersonating a police
officer is a third degree felony my
friend
well well i live to all fans of mine at
this whole time as fans of mine
i'm a genius all right thanks bobo he's
amazing
i'm a genius he says with such authority
kind of is i mean who else gets on
channel 13.